I am ill I'm coming for you first okay
it's not okay
double kill you rien you're crap the
South the North we've got the music
scene on lockdown
we've got storm Z Bugsy Malone is I'm
suppose you can even hear music over the
sound a constant drizzle through the
rain in Perm unique champions for now
but listen that trophies coming home
back down south we've got the best young
ball is in the prim oh you mad we've got
some ballers up north listen I've got my
squad and they're ready to shut you up
only one way to settle this
my squad is made up of some of the
sharpest shoe is in the north
we've got Liverpool's Rising Stars Harry
Wilson and Riaan Brewster unless the
city's main man James Madison so here
you have to get past these boys I've got
Arsenal dangerous duo Rob holding an ml
Smith row and also Chelsea baller keep
an amputee the first two rounds are a
classic for V for Team Deathmatch North
versus south first team to the target
score which is one point it's all about
wiping out the opposition part in black
ops for you've gotta play as a team or
you're toast age is gonna get it who's
there other player I am ill I'm coming
for you first
I'm coming for all of you watch your
back let's go come on the boys these
boys in the south don't want it how come
we're just four men I have thrown a
fried the checks cleared let's go to
work
you know they're gonna concrete this
door man just thought oh [ __ ]
their shots already I don't know that
means did I just drop a man down I was
going for long go 0:08 that's why I like
having you on my team
oh [ __ ] already are very mind
matignon already I've got your back
overnight - I know where I'll slide it
off and touch I've been tough oh look at
that make you miserable him El Capitan
captain lead a legend on us you in it
eyes bi mát ah
eh I told you I'm going with you double
kill ya boys we need some communication
follow me wow wow you're in trouble now
Crashdown you're not dealing with that
field me shushing whoa oh yeah that's
not fair come on hey we won this
everyone it let's just come pout
yeah way one way I want victory
okay so first game it's not okay I'm so
confident if it's Joey I'm [ __ ] for X if
I get back into that
[Laughter]
one minute gone boys ninety-nine cute
eye behind boys one minute to go
this is it this is for glory this is for
the north let's do it okay chips and
gravy Liverpool the decider each team
will be dropped into a public game of
blackout the new Call of Duty battle
royale as a team of four only get one
life so it's a fight to the end of the
game as the last man standing
the team that ranks the highest takes
the point it's as simple as that
but watch out because the competition is
fierce and it's gonna be 80 other
players out there looking to win it's
all about strategy and working as a team
and to make things interesting if the
winning team ranks in the top five at a
whole game they'll get an additional
point meaning we'll have a tie-break on
our hands now why does the dump look
yeah
[Laughter]
throw it all subsequent H&M someone come
up said someone come upstairs I'm dying
I'm dying Emile Emile come upstairs in
my mind you to stay in there and do we
know if they're in it well baby you
should by fiber people this is boys
house I'll go first without one before I
was outstanding
honestly money the match performance
right there absolutely third one matter
first - yeah Kyle give me one sentence
on your performance what you for I'll
give you one word diabolical I'd agree
with that yeah calm Wattenberg he was
giving it in a big chap I mean you know
what we had some man-of-the-match
performance is right here just don't act
like you were amazing I saw your
resource worried about me aren't the
guys
using my DNS chatting all kinds of crud
you're the worst you can do your team's
decent but you know what you played well
you three plays well Josh you were there
you spectate you for him I was the
captain made captain lead a legend
one more thing yeah what yeah yeah